[Musique]
entre lac et montagne au coeur des alpes
suisses
au bord du lac léman au pays des banques
et de la discrétion
vous allez découvrir l'endroit le plus
secret du pays
au milieu d'une zone industrielle à deux
pas de la frontière française
à genève le bord franc surveillée par
des caméras
entouré de grease et de barbelés ces
entrepôts sont une zone sous douane où
transitent des marchandises en attente
d'être réexpédié à l'étranger
c'est devenu aujourd'hui une zone de
stockage permanent
soixante mille mètres carrés d'entrepôts
loué par la ville de genève à des
transporteurs ou directement à des
particuliers pour qu'ils y entrepose
leurs biens derrière ces portes anonyme
fermé à double tour
on trouve de l'or des diamants
c'est aussi la plus grande cave à vins
du monde 3 millions de bouteilles sont
rangés les plus grands crus des
bouteilles à 500 à 1000 à 2000 euros
y prennent tranquillement de la valeur
en vieillissant à température et
hygrométrie constante
[Musique]
les constructions sont anti sismiques
les portes résiste aux explosifs et pour
protéger ses trésors de l' incendie une
salle spéciale abrite des centaines
d'extincteurs qui peuvent être
déclenchées à tout moment
si le port franc déploie autant de
précautions c'est surtout que derrière
ces portes dorment des oeuvres d'art
inestimable
il y en aurait pour des dizaines de
milliards d'euros peut-être le plus
grand musée du monde mais un musée que
personne n'a le droit de visiter le port
franc de genève est l'un des secrets les
mieux gardés de rabat dans ses coffres
des picasso des léonard de vinci
des milliers d'antiquités un trésor dont
personne ne connaît l'ampleur ni la
valeur
c'est sûr qu'on trouverait jamais un
répertoire de toutes les toiles qui sont
aux ports français
c'est ça secret qu'elle garde et vous
savez pas s'il y en a 300 3300 secret
aussi le nom des propriétaires des
oeuvres
le but du jeu étant qu'on ne sache pas
qui vend quoi à qui et c'est là que va
s'insérer le port franc récemment
plusieurs affaires ont éclaboussé cette
institution spoliation des biens juifs
blanchiment fraude fiscale il est
difficile de serre si le tableau était
conservée très discrètement dans le
portrait le port franc de genève l
eldorado des marchands des riches
héritiers et des fraudeurs il y ferait à
faire ensemble
ni vu ni connu